but john before you go i want to mention  uh one of the fine individuals who helps  you be heard every morning brian is  leaving the show i am told after eight  years  i want to give him a special shout out  in part because he'll be walking out the  door i hear in a pair of shoes  inspired by the sneakers i often wear  here on set  wow you that that is very true thank you  for the shout out and on behalf of brian  there's brian in the corner there  uh tony thank you very much for the  shout out absolutely we will miss  brian enormously he's responsible for  all the sound effects and all the music  we hear during the program so  thank you sir we'll see you on cbs this  morning and yes he is absolutely rocking  your footwear  wearing it better than me good luck  brian